so with New York Comic Con this week I
have not had a chance to prep my normal
fare of videos with regards to a history
of the mobile universe and the character
discussions and so on and so forth and
so what I wanted to do was bring you
guys content while I'm away but I
thought it'd be kind of a cool idea to
talk about the origin story of Doctor
Doom and the reason why is because
Doctor Doom is amazing and his origin
story really matches up with how awesome
he is so the origin of Doctor Doom comes
to us from writer Edie Brubaker in the
form of a six-part series called the
books of doom then the books of doom are
done in a documentary esque form and we
actually don't find out until halfway
through the first issue that dooms being
interviewed but the books of doom
basically provide us narrative from
other people that have been a part of
his former life and so it's a comic book
counterpart to you quite literally
sitting in front of a TV and watching an
interview on a character that features
snippets from different people over the
course of that character's life and so
it's extremely well done but it also
ties very well into the original origin
story of Doctor Doom that appeared in
Fantastic Four annual number two by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby did actually it fills
in the holes and it builds on that and
this is kind of a big deal because the
origin story of doom wasn't given until
like two or three years after his first
appearance and even then it was it was a
pretty reasonable size origin but it
left a lot of questions in terms of his
life in terms of how he came to be who
he was so on and so forth and so what
Roux Baker did is he came back and
updated this with some of the modern
content for for Marvel comics that had
been you know expanded by different
writers over the course of Doom's and
the Fantastic Four's histories and he
just put in a really concise six-part
series for us and so what this does is
this picks up with Doctor Doom more or
less telling us about his birth and what
he says is his intelligence basically
seemed to emerge when he was still in
the womb he was developing skills that
normally are not prevalent in children
until they're you know three or four
years old he was developing this while
he was in the womb and a lot of people
would say that that was never true that
perhaps it was just dooms own
imagination but doom tells us that in
his mind a lot of it had to do with the
fact that his mother was dipping into
magic into dark magic specifically now
this comes to a head in the form of the
fact that dr. Doom's father tries to
reason with his mother
and there's a couple reasons for this
the first is that as a Romani dr. Doom's
family already had a stigma of delving
into black magic the issue here is that
his mother was legitimately doing it and
so she was developing a bad reputation
even within the Romani community itself
the other half of this was that word
would reach the ears of the Baron of
their territory and if it did he would
inevitably have her killed and would
probably kill off the entire tribe just
to make sure nobody else got any of the
same ideas but the problem here is that
in the mind of dr. Doom's mother there
at the behest of this Baron this baron
is very cruel this barons very sadistic
and their idea is that because they're
basically living day by day trying to
stay alive if she can amass the power
necessary she can basically freed them
from the yoke of oppression by killing
off the Baron and his forces allowing
them to live without any without any
issue the problem here is that when she
invokes this magic she effectively sells
her soul now we'll find out that she
sells her soul later on but the issue is
that in response for the magic that she
invoked the price was that all the
children in the village were killed
now dr. doom was spared of this fate
from being killed as part of all these
children and we'll find out why later on
but the result is that because of her
actions the villagers had cast dooms
mother out of the village and the result
was that she was eventually tracked down
by the Barons men who were looking for
who it was that had killed so many of
his soldiers and when they found her
they basically killed her out in the
woods now her father I guess her husband
eventually found her but was only able
to meet with her long enough to
basically say goodbye and so after this
she was buried in an unmarked grave but
the problem here was that to the minds
of the villagers her husband should have
known dooms father should have known
what was going on not only that because
he was the leader this is compounded by
the fact that as the leader he should
know everything that's going on and so
this presents two scenarios either he's
a terrible leader because he didn't know
or he's a terrible leader because he did
know and chose not to tell everyone but
regardless of the situation the
villagers basically vote to cast dr.
Doom's father out of the village now
this changes they end up reversed in
their opinion and the reason why is
because as
child doom was still extremely
intelligent but he was also very cunning
and he was also very ruthless and what
he told the villagers was that if they
cast his family out if they kick him and
his father out that not only will he
grow up to become his mother's son and
invoke the same kind of magic that she
did but he'll come back to the village
he'll find them even if they're not
there wherever they happen to be and he
will bring upon them a terror far beyond
anything that his mother did now this
these are some cold words for a kid and
you know maybe doom was bluffing maybe
doom was being serious because of the
way he turned out it would stand to
reason he was being serious especially
with what will see later on here but the
fact remains that because they were
terrified for their lives in the sense
that they were dealing with things they
didn't understand they ultimately let
doom and his family or doom in his
father stay the problem with this was
that despite being part of the community
they were still outcasts you know they
were they were never looked at the same
way again and so while they never really
talked about dooms mother it was always
kind of a back thought in the mind of
everyone it was always they're
constantly on the move now because of
what she did they're constantly evading
the forces of the Baron because of what
she did she's basically become sort of a
taboo you know to speak about within the
community itself now not all was bad for
Doom and in fact he encountered a girl
named valaria and it was actually a girl
that he kind of fell in love with I
wouldn't say that for Doom it was love
just because of the fact that his
intelligence and his ruthlessness and
the fact that he lost his mother kind of
stripped him of that that concept but it
was for Doom as close as he could get to
being in love but the fact remains here
that for him Valerius sort of
represented a brighter life
Valerius sort of represented the way
things could be that things could be a
bit better than simply being a social
outcast within the community the
downside to this is that dooms father is
summoned by the Baron because again the
Baron doesn't know that they were the
ones behind or I guess that dooms mother
was the one behind the the attack he was
simply just soldiers retaliating for her
actions and so what happens here is when
dooms father leaves of course Victor
freaks out he's he's very upset about
this travelling to the Baron this really
the worst case scenario in his mind that
his father's going to be killed but when
his father comes back he immediately
grabs doom and they take off now Victor
is told why
what he's told is that the Barons wife
was riddled with cancer and the Baron
had looked to dooms father who was
perceived to be one of the best doctors
you know in the Romani territories as
someone that could heal his wife the
problem was that because his wife was
riddled with cancer there was nothing
that Victor's father could do because
the cancer was so far along and the
result was that the Baron basically
blamed Victor's father for his wife's
death and so what happens is Victor and
his father basically go on the run to
avoid the soldiers of the Baron who are
inevitably going to track them down and
try to kill them you know at the orders
of the Baron so while they're hiding
while there while they're remaining on
the run the issue is the soldiers seem
to be hunting them to the very very end
there they hunt him as far as they can
now eventually the soldiers stop but the
issue with this is they're so far into
the mountains where it's freezing
freezing to death is a very real
possibility now this doesn't really
happen Dhoom wakes up and finds his
father's arms around him and it seems as
though his father's dead but we actually
learned he's not that his father
survived the experience he probably has
frostbite in certain places hypothermia
for sure but doom's father is basically
taken away once he comes back to the
village he's taken away by the Baron
presumably to be killed at the Barons
request and so what happens is that
following this Victor basically falls
into a into he basically retreats him to
himself for him his mother died because
of her you know because of invoking
witchcraft his father died because of
the actions of the Baron he's basically
sort of reaching a state of mental
instability but at the same time his
mind's never been so clear and so what
he does is he basically delves into
witchcraft in the same form that his
mother had but what he does is he also
blends it with technology now again this
is just an indication of how intelligent
Doom is there was a saying at least if
I'm getting it correctly that magic is
simply a level of technology people
can't understand yet and this is what
doom does doom basically starts blending
magic and technology to create the
illusion that is technologically
advanced without people coming to the
realization that he's invoking magic and
so he's basically tricking the eyes in
the mind of almost anybody that he comes
across then because he's able to do this
we could he's able to blend these two
things he presents himself to be a
formidable Challenger and he basically
begins leading a swath throughout the
entire territory where all these
different Romani camps are located and
starts killing off all
soldiers and eventually kills off the
Baron drives him out of there in its
entirety now but something else is also
interesting here is that prior to the
Barons death he had put out a bounty on
Victor Von Doom and Victor Von Doom
actually comes across a scenario where a
hunter finds him and the hunter realizes
that it is Victor Von Doom and the
bounty so high that this hunter could
basically live the rest of his life in
comfort if he hands doom over and so in
response for the first time in his life
Doom actually chokes a man to death with
his bare hands now there's a huge
difference between doom killing people
using devices and doom killing people
with his own hands it makes things more
tangible you know it makes things more
realistic it really ties to Doom himself
because the death of a person isn't the
result of some device he created it's
the result of him physically choking the
life out of that person and so this
moment if there were ever a time when
Doom crossed a line that he couldn't
come back from this was it he was
basically on the path to becoming dr.
doom to becoming ruthless to becoming
guile to becoming a cruel but also you
know somewhat honorable and so as this
first issue begins to wrap up we
basically find that Victor Von Doom is
tracked down by a man from the United
States and it receives an invitation to
be educated in the United States because
of his intelligence but without being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end let me know what you guys think
about this series of the moment because
I think it's actually pretty cool
I think books of doom is a really really
good series but but it even let me know
what you guys think and I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]
I